this show is brought to you by me undies
go to meundies.com joey right now to get
20 percent off of your first order
that's bnds.com joey right now and check
out all their men's and women's
underwear you're going to get 20 off of
your first order at meundies.com joey
and don't forget shipping is always free
in the us and canada
the show is also brought to you by
texture
the texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines anytime
anywhere using your smartphone or tablet
and the best part is texture is offering
the listeners of the church of what's
happening now a free trial right now
when you go to texture.com joey that's
texture.com joey
texture.com
joey
this show is also brought to you by pet
net
stop worrying about feeding your pets
the wrong amount of food every day the
pet net smart feeder will feed the
healthiest portions at the right time
every time automatically get your pet
net smart feeder plus free shipping when
you go to shop petnet dot com slash joey
that's shoppetnet.com
joey shop pet net.com joey
here we go
another fun-filled evening with uncle
joey and his goomba of death lee syed
a little sylvester
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
kick that muley kicked that mew ain't
got time to [ __ ] around lee
goalie
oh [ __ ]
here we go
wednesday
the 19th
do you think [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] you're going for it no
matter what
what's the story there [ __ ] that
everything all right in your world i
love that you said that the my bottom
button is fighting and it's always oh
it's stressing out right now stressing i
can never as it like i can't that's the
one thing i'm looking forward to about
being
any skinnier
is just like i can always like the top
button always works but the further down
you go oh [ __ ] [ __ ] nightmare and
it's worse i hate having one open when
you look down after like like after a
bar mitzvah after a wedding or dancing
and you find it like your shirt's all
open you're sweating oh they see his
stomach hair and [ __ ] all dressed
do you have a lot of hair i haven't
covered [ __ ] hair no no thank god i
don't even have my [ __ ] legs my
daughter's got hairy legs which shocks
the [ __ ] out of me
i pick her up i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] and you don't see them they're
just these little blonde tentacles of
[ __ ] hair the curling [ __ ]
it's uh
when you i bought a shirt
like in the prime of my diet like when i
was at 270 and i put it on for the
baptism
oh yeah yeah i remember the [ __ ]
buttons were about to bust
and i was never so cracked in my life
like i thought
i didn't know what happened to the shirt
i thought i didn't try it on when i got
it
i was kind of [ __ ] stuck
and i finally said well you know and now
the shirt fits that's awesome now the
shirt the buttons aren't stressing the
[ __ ] out you know but it's like when you
see a woman with the with the yoga pants
and she's putting them to a stress test
like you see the skin you see the tattoo
but they're black pants oh yeah i love
this stretching those [ __ ] i
love yoga pants like everybody wears
them all [ __ ] day now
women just say [ __ ] it we're just
wearing yoga pants which i'm not mad at
you it's kind of interesting with the
nice sneakers and [ __ ]
it's funny they've started wearing
sweatshirts around their waist at the
gym
because guys are so creepy
like they just have to now like because
it was it was it is kind of weird
sometimes especially around here some of
the gyms like they're like it looks like
they're dressed like a porn shoot at a
gym
well you go to that 24-hour fitness
which is always a [ __ ]
it's always a [ __ ] actorville oh yeah
guys you know chicks that get dolled up
with a hat with the ponytail coming out
of the hat did you ever
like uh go i guess hit on a girl at the
gym like i always hear about people
meeting people at the gym no chubby guys
can't meet people at the gym no no no no
you know what i say three words at the
[ __ ] gym
do you know that three words that's it
three words
there was one guy at the ymca when i
first started my mission like eight
years ago
there was one guy at the [ __ ] ymca
that was 70 something maybe 80. he
looked great god bless him but it was
just social activity oh yeah yeah his
social activity was to get to the y at 9
00 a.m and stay there till 7
and like do a little bit of this but
talk to you but he would talk to you
when you were in the middle of your
workout and they perceived to [ __ ]
talk to you and talk and you're like
listen
so it was got to the point where i got
the heavy uh
iphones the the speakers and i put them
on my ears and i just
and it's the rudest thing i was raised
better than that but
i got an hour
i got an hour 15 minutes i got an
appointment i gotta go do something i
gotta pick somebody up i gotta go do
this
i you know i got an hour and a half
you know what i'm saying i don't have
time to stop for 15 minutes to [ __ ]
talk to you about the weather or nothing
i gotta do a [ __ ] workout plus i
gotta jump on the elliptical
but there's people who go to the gym to
chitchat it drives me [ __ ] crazy
it drives me crazy you know i'm getting
a bag for the garage oh you are getting
a bad shot oh yeah she won't let me go
get it because she wants to get it for
me for christmas oh and i'm getting the
the weight set like a basic weight set
just to be able to like last night
couldn't fall asleep
one in the morning you bust out a little
workout and [ __ ] you're not gonna go to
sleep you're gonna take a nice shower
but at least you'll be tired and you're
gonna work on a late night i used to
work out
late night for years when i had my own
type of [ __ ] that i could just go out to
were you like doing it at the end of
your day or were you staying up i was
working at the end of my day 10 o'clock
when i was your age i could you know you
still got energy at ten right you know
when you when you're [ __ ] uh
when you're young 20 35
you could work
come home take a breather
and then at nine get motivated to
[ __ ] go hit it which is a big
motivation
that's a very big motivation for a guy
like me now today it doesn't work
for maybe you or some other people a lot
of people can't wake up early and go to
the [ __ ] gym and get that much
stuff thrown out i'm not mad at you
that's just the way life is i don't have
energy to go now
oh yeah i don't have the [ __ ] energy
to go at eight o'clock at night i just
don't i can't focus
i got other [ __ ] on my mind when i go
early in the morning it's good because
it breaks that
it breaks that stupidity that you have
all day in half at 12 o'clock you know
especially if you're writing and you're
sitting there
and you're stuck with a [ __ ] subject
or something
it's always great to get up in the
middle then go bust it out and come back
take a shower eat something get back to
it for two or three hours
it's nice
it's it's hard though
in like
like the middle of the day for me is
tough just because i feel like i can
never get going like you wake up super
early and start working i don't wake up
until 8 30 sometimes
so for me to like go and work out at 12
like that's why i like the 9 a.m and
it's tough like because a lot of times i
don't want to leave in the morning to be
very honest so that's like
to be honest with everyone
ever since cowbell's closed i've been
kind of [ __ ] up and i've just in the
last week or so started going back and
it's uh
it's harder when like that's why
i think that's why people like jiu jitsu
and all that like i like kettlebells
it's time when you're just going by
yourself it's hard not to stay motivated
it's not motivation but just
just to get up just to get out of bed or
leave the office or whatever
i just know i was really heavy at one
time
and i know that i never want to feel
that way again number one and i never
want to start over again like i never
want to stop working out for a year and
have to start over again at 55.
i always try to do something even when
my back was hurt you know this week
weekend i went to chicago with you i
only got to work out friday
you know but i worked out and that
worked out pretty hard and i gave a good
[ __ ] sweat and the shirt's still in
the [ __ ]
luggage oh my god that thing's gonna
smell like [ __ ] cottage cheese it was
still wet when i checked out on sunday
so i put it in the front
oh okay so i just put in the front now
when i didn't have a bag it was right
there i was running out of [ __ ] door
but i always try to do something the
last uh
i went to the chiropractor monday said
take off till thursday
but yesterday i walked and today i
walked like a [ __ ] you know i
put my walking my running sneakers on
the there were new balances yeah i just
went today you know and i came back and
i was wet
and then i did some uh [ __ ] whatever
things
i did a couple curls couple push-ups a
bunch of sit-ups
how many times do you think you've
started over i must have started over at
least four times no not since since 2000
when i started going for this exercise
routine i have not started over i don't
get that sore anymore
it's unless i try something new right
like along the line you try something
new you will get a little sore it's
different muscle groups and whatnot it's
tough
to stay motivated but i know the other
side you know
when you're in your late 20s
your mid-30s you could take a couple
years off and you could survive with
just doing little things and keeping an
eye on your diet
but when you get back into it when
you're 40 it's really hard again
you know that's why if i know what i
know now i would have never stopped
i would have always kept some type of
program that's why i say something like
jiu jitsu
because you're going to do it for the
rest of your life you're going to be
doing that and mixing it with other
things but that's your foundation
it could be karate it could be kung fu
it could be what the [ __ ] you want it
could be ballet
it could be pilates you need something
that you like
that you know you don't like for a long
time you know the guys are there there's
girls there you can talk to people
it's kind of takes you away from your
norm it takes you out of your [ __ ]
norm which
if you know anything about me i love
doing right i hate it i love
since i was a [ __ ] kid
i loved doing different [ __ ] you could
only play basketball on 38th street for
so long you get to know everybody's
moves let's take this show over the sea
caucus let's take this show to [ __ ]
16th street to gilmore you know what i'm
saying let's take this and that's how
you gauge who the [ __ ] you are
it's tough the first couple days no
matter what you do when you go outside
your comfort zone
but it's all so interesting
and you get it out of the way you go you
know what i did it i don't like it
see i don't find it interesting like to
me it's scary
for like the first month like if
starting a new job knew anything to me
i don't i don't think i avoided in some
senses i avoid certain things like
working out and other stuff but like
i'll do other things that are new to me
but like
i get so much anxiety about anything new
i don't like it it's
like
i wish i could be excited about trying
something outside of my comfort zone
because i'm not at all
you know we're two different age things
here so
there's a lot of things i've tried over
the years like i didn't like uh
amusement parks but i didn't like
amusement parks as a kid
i didn't like the whole [ __ ] drama
and like seeing people puke on rides
i didn't like know that i was always a
kid that got carsick have you changed a
lot since since you were a kid like your
personality what you like what you enjoy
it's a tough question
i mean we all had to evolve a little bit
and they're sure like that you know i i
torture you about the food you eat the
same food you ate not
as bad as the [ __ ] you ate you know i
grew up in jersey where i hamburger
deluxes
open steaks you know there was no
wendy's you know wendy's was the first
one on tunnelly avenue mcdonald's has
always been around like cancer
uh you know uh kentucky fried chicken's
always been around jack-in-the-box was
always up in queens arthur treaches fish
and chips
that was like a fish and chip place i
never really ate there except once when
i was a kid in the bronx or something
but there was the abundance
there was no [ __ ] subway
there was no [ __ ] j j brothers there
was no jersey pete's mics whatever the
[ __ ] it is those sandwiches
there was none of that [ __ ] you know
i was thinking about you today because i
was
thinking about my deepest moments even
when i lived in that [ __ ] rocket ship
i ate good
like i never [ __ ] ate bad
like up the corner for me was the palms
when i lived in the rocket ship and the
palmer's had like nice italian bread and
like prosciutto and ham and i'd eat one
of those i never thought of [ __ ]
going to a fast food restaurant
i never thought of getting like a
like all those years i never thought of
any of that [ __ ] i got pizza
there was a place where i was growing up
the midtown lounge and they used to have
a chef
the one brother was a chef and every day
he served
a [ __ ] lunch that was superb for
eight bucks seven bucks
and i made it a point to go there
because it was salad soup
i got all the four [ __ ] nutrients it
was a dessert
you know i've never been a drinker with
my meals i [ __ ] hate drinking with my
meals right yeah you know i hate
anything extra anything going in my
stomach with food
but i never it's like you said to me the
one day yeah i like trying new things
joey when it comes to food you don't
like trying nothing your girlfriend
likes trying new things and when you
want to be suave you want oh sure i'll
try nothing you don't want to try no
things
food i don't hear okay i don't know when
you drive past the shittiest restaurant
like where you go for chicken teriyaki
i'm surprised you haven't been dead yet
over there like i i will there i won't
go in that [ __ ] mall
really like that whole mall gives me the
creeps
like that whole [ __ ] strip mall gives
me the creeps
wouldn't that give me the creeps and i
was thinking yes i didn't well because
it's more a lot what the way i was
thinking was
just
how you live your life like just
i was i was talking to someone today and
they were saying like you shouldn't
fight who you are you shouldn't like for
me like what i've been struggling with a
lot recently
is part of me wants to be an
entrepreneur like i like it
but part of me also
i'm not sure if i'm cut out for it to be
honest and it's not
like it's not this but just like running
a business
and they were saying like i was talking
to them and they're like oh i ran a
business for a while
but i i i i thrive as part of a team
and part of what i've been
going back and forth with is
like would i be
like what should like what should i do
like should i join a team like you said
when someone help someone
grow a podcast or should i do something
on my own
and part of me wants to the challenge of
doing it myself but part of me isn't
sure if i can do it okay
here it is [ __ ] simple
okay
20 years ago 10 years ago i would say
you know what lee
go get yourself a kid your age
and
you know okay so you go get you go get
part of a team okay
first though what team do you want to be
a part of i don't know okay right now i
know maybe
three people four people who know as
much as you as producing podcasts one of
them is red man
you know jamie yeah vicki pezza you know
we have a lot of people that have been
doing this since day one okay
so now that's some options for you there
for you to open up this business or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do now at
the other part let's say you do find of
a team
like all these other podcast groups that
are going on there popping up
but then between you and i and joe rogan
and hari
we do the podcast i love coming here oh
yeah to me i wish i could come here five
[ __ ] days a week
instead of going on the road i just
couldn't support my family five [ __ ]
days a week
so
i need to go on the road and i and i
love doing this but we have it down to
two days a week right now and it's the
law diminishing returns i just want to
do this for a while so i don't want to
over
uh saturated saturate myself and
starting six podcasts and trying to be a
part of everybody's buyer i'm happy just
doing this with you
you're experienced
let's say you join up with somebody
who's been doing it for two years and i
did radio for 18 years the radio's dead
radio's dead get rid of that [ __ ]
voice radio's dead okay this is podcast
and i want you to put your emotions
which a lot of people don't do they
still think this is radio
and that's why that podcast doesn't
thrive as well because they still think
this is radio
so you have two options you could go
with some people who are not as
experienced as you and you got to split
the money up the same [ __ ] juice
okay how you gonna feel about that
that's numb
number two
do you
i think the ideas that you have
should be you and as time goes on
you're gonna hire somebody who in turn
you're going to make to be a miniature
you
and they understand the [ __ ] uh
what's going on here
but
i can see what's the decision
entrepreneur means
i was doing paperwork today i was making
copies and filing and stapling
and i enjoyed it you know i was doing it
for the podcast i was getting ios and
doing this and you got to open up your
calendar and mark where it goes now i
could take somebody
and pay them 12 15 bucks an hour to do
that
but you know what i wouldn't be i
wouldn't know what was going on
i want to know what's going on
and that's the problem with me i always
want to know what's going on everybody
who fails is because they spread
themselves out too thin
and they don't have control of two or
three things
and meanwhile when you go there they get
800 mics instead of 300 mics and they're
drinking [ __ ] 22 water instead of
regular water and they got the extreme
i'm saying like little [ __ ] things
that
they wouldn't understand because they're
not paying for it
right yeah there's little [ __ ] things
along the lines so these are the
decisions you have to do
this is why i never spread myself thing
because i wanted to always know what the
right hand and the left hand are doing
you want to call me a control freak call
me what the [ __ ] you want
but show me a guy who's got [ __ ] 19
things going on that could look at all
of them that could oversee all of them
and the only way you learn that is by
losing it when you think you could do
everything i.e
i could do this i can get on a plane
come back shoot a movie i gotta have a
blog on monday i told timmy that i'll do
his podcast i told this guy to do his
podcast i told and your calendar is
unbearable right oh you have no control
nothing and it's the law of diminishing
returns you don't know what you're
saying on these [ __ ] podcasts you
don't know what you're saying on stage
anymore
so this is what i did
from
2003 from like 2000 to 2005. this is how
i was living okay
you follow me and i got my lumps i made
some enemies
okay because i couldn't cover all these
dates
i couldn't do this guy's movie and do
this
i couldn't do a thousand things so now i
stop i take a deep breath and i think
and i think a couple things how is this
going to affect my life right now
what's affect my life do i want to stay
out of the house for four [ __ ] days
shooting your stupid movie in marina del
rey
for 100 a day from towards my insurance
not [ __ ] really right no you know
there's a thousand options in my life
now as you go along with your life
your options become
less because you have more
responsibility
are you with me yeah right now let me
tell you something right now
you're 28 years old if i came to you
right now and said listen i got a
carnival cruise line
you go on a ship for three months of
[ __ ] time you're gonna do podcast on
the [ __ ] ship
we're gonna pay you 60 000 for
three months
you could do it oh yeah of course you
could
give paul a big hug
big [ __ ] hug give it three dumplings
and say i'll see you in three months dog
and guess what you're only gonna be home
for a week when you come back
and you're gonna go out again
and these are the responsibilities these
are the things the decisions that you
make as a young man
that caves your career caves your life
because you think there's something at
home there's a lot of things i had no
responsibilities
i didn't leave north bergen new jersey
because since day one i was quested to
head west once my mother died
and i saw where my life was going i had
nothing holding me there
a girl
would i give a [ __ ]
what girl
between a girl and a life you got to
pick your life right ellie and girl
always be there i looked a girl in
boston yeah absolutely you know it's
kind of weird all these things so
right now
if somebody comes to me and says hey we
want you to go to south africa for six
months and do county we'll pay you all
big amounts of money but you can't come
home for six months i can't do that
i can't do that
i'm trying to raise a kid and have a
wife and have a family that's more
important to me than [ __ ] anything
i could always make a living dog
i could always make a living
do you think i became right now what i
do i'm an entrepreneur
for the last 26 years i can look in the
face and say i'm a [ __ ] entrepreneur
did i ever tell anybody i was an
entrepreneur
no did i ever get a business card and go
to dentist with my [ __ ] stupid
friends
and salmon entrepreneur whatever the
[ __ ] the word is no
because i just did it
and i and i got better and i failed
along the way you got to keep paperwork
you got to do this you're going to be a
good comment get it right you got to
write your dates down and uh you know if
you want to be a good plumber
if i say to you tomorrow i'm going to
hire you as a plumber lead you know what
joey i'm going to work with joey joey
isn't rich
he's he doesn't struggle though she's
got a wife two kids
they're both in private school
joey doesn't go out for expensive
dinners every night but he's got a nice
plumbing business you know what mama
learned to be a plumber okay first thing
you're gonna do is you're gonna get a
notebook
because every day at the end of the year
now you don't you won't know this
for two years i'm telling you now
you're gonna get a notebook and every
day you're gonna write down what you
learned with the date who you worked
with what tools you learned
so you you get everything you do
remember when you're a plumbing
electrician construction guy they're
basically paying paying you to solve
problems
okay every day what's a plumber doing he
installs toilets he can just come up and
do 10 toilets a day don't work that way
because each situation is going to be
[ __ ] different uh-huh this one's
going to need ladders to carry the
toilet the toilet don't fit through the
[ __ ] door
the old pipe was in there there's always
a by the way stuff you don't get paid
for installing toilets you can paint the
deal with the by the way whether you're
an electrician concrete whatever the
[ __ ] you're doing there's always a by
the way
a job just does not go smoothly it seems
like there's that in life your
experience is what helps that job move
along oh i know what to do cut that
piece of wall off there's an existing
wall in there and also you said they go
what the [ __ ] does this guy know he's
been doing it for 20 years
he knows every wire in these [ __ ]
walls
it's the same thing in any [ __ ]
career you know i didn't know this when
i became an electrician that i write
this [ __ ] down i started writing it down
after a year
what pipes i bent you know how thick the
pipes were just stupid [ __ ]
and when you and you would like go over
it at night or what would you do
when i go over it at night yeah we go
over tonight i go over it at the end of
the week but that goes back to grammar
school
when i sit you down and we talk about
the world of eight the the war of 19
whatever or the holocaust what happened
as the teachers were talking about it
you're writing notes
and when you go home that night what do
you do if you're like you're
not not me i didn't do this
i'm sure you did you're a nice kid you
go look over those nose
and every night you look over those nuts
for a half hour 20 minutes so guess what
when finals comes
you're a bad [ __ ]
you know this stuff already see i [ __ ]
up
and uh we all [ __ ] up no this is this
is what i'm saying to you we've all
[ __ ] up but i didn't i had and it
sounds like it sounds weird i think i've
talked about it before
me knowing that i was kind of smart i
was smart enough not to study
[ __ ] me up i wish i never knew that
because
i never i never would go over my notes
and i would never almost take notes
unless like i was interested or like it
was a class that i was terrible in
i would take notes but english history
my last english class i took in college
didn't read one of the books
i would listen to what everyone else was
saying i would say i know a lot of
people do that i know that's not a new
thing in school
but that's why
it's hard
that's why i've been
uh stressing about being an entrepreneur
because i feel like that work ethic my
work ethic is there when i'm working for
somebody when i'm working at like cvs
like that's a manual i can see i can do
it but for for me it's a great work
ethic but it's your organizational
skills
blows and it takes you too long to get
up and get out
that's that that'll always kill you get
up get out that bob marley said that 22
years ago
go up four you're right whatever get up
get up whatever the [ __ ] it is right and
that's
a problem not with me i don't really
give a [ __ ] but everybody i've seen that
doesn't have the ability to rock and
roll in the morning that's not a good
ability i want you to be able to rock
and roll the drop of a hat
i want you to be able to [ __ ] you
know sometimes we oversleep
it's that guy that wakes up and goes i
got this
i'm overslept but watch me put this
together in 15 [ __ ] minutes
oh yeah so
uh it takes you quick to get up in the
morning
you know i know you get up before
sometimes and you hit the computer
and you look at numbers and different
things which that's a great quality
that's that listen that's what that's
what i'm saying
you want to be an entrepreneur
go for it lee you have all the [ __ ]
tools
you have all the [ __ ] tools
there's nothing to sweat here
as long as you do the work
before you go into it i want you to make
a checklist
i want you to really know the work
you're getting yourself into so you
could tell everybody else what you're
doing so everybody understands your
schedule
and go for it
the most important thing any of this
[ __ ] is going for it
you know you learn the most after a
failure
you know i sit here with you now and i
talk about this thing with school
one of my [ __ ] biggest favors when i
got left back because i didn't get to
look back because i was stupid
i gotta look back because i got lazy
right yeah yeah and i thought i could
beat the system and you're not going to
beat the system i'm glad i got that
lesson handed to me i had the same
problem you had
but something else came out of me when i
got left back i learned something i
learned how hard i wasn't as intelligent
as you i know right now today
i hear my wife talk i'm not intelligent
i hear joe rogan speak and ari and all
you guys that are really really really
college educated
my smarts isn't in that department
i have a different type of smarts
okay and along the way it's built up
the smart where you guys are at from
reading books and
going online and talking to people and
asking questions on a particular topic
that you're interested in you know i
mean i'm not
book smart like a lot of you guys but i
know one thing i could be
because i'll take the same book you're
[ __ ] reading i'll break that
[ __ ] down into chunks
and i'll pull out of that book what i
need to know what's important out of
that book and that's what i know how to
do
and i'll get it downward to [ __ ] word
like that's what after i got left back
was where i learned to review
my schoolwork every night
even after my mother died that year in
high school
i had like an hour when you get home
whenever everybody's showering and [ __ ]
i would look over tomorrow's work
before i went out and did the hits i
asked that i'd talk about and smoke the
22 joints with the avillos and all those
savages behind this shed
i looked over my work you know why
because those guys were book smart
anthony steven villa was book smart
lubes was really book smart at mit
clan conti was men's and men's fernie
was men's and men's but i always had so
and i learned that after i got left back
that i was a hard worker
that was a hard worker when i knew how
to organize
and i listened to that [ __ ] teacher
i listened to what was important to her
i got to learn what was important to her
and that's what i excelled in
and that's how you get a haze and beach
yeah
well what do you mean important to her
like what she emphasized
you know when something's important to
somebody
when i make you go through pages and i
go don't worry about that worry about
this
that's important
she's going to say different things in
her speech
that are important to her
now do you know what quality you're
learning there when you listen to her
and you're trying to figure this out
salesmanship
because you're listening to their needs
it's the same [ __ ] daily
you take their needs and you're blasted
against them
so what are you doing with her you know
what she's gonna ask you on the [ __ ]
quiz what you've been talking about
what's important to her
and you get to know what's important to
her and you get to know down to the
[ __ ] t
and you get great grades i'm not saying
that was a [ __ ] phi beta kappa
but for the amount of drugs i was doing
with no supervision and [ __ ] i didn't do
a bad [ __ ] job i didn't quit school i
wasn't forced to quit school because i
was stupid
i quit school because i was stupid
i didn't think about the future but now
i'm thinking about the new [ __ ] i should
have quit two years early
if i knew what i knew now i would have
quit two [ __ ] years early jesus
because i kind of got my ged and still
gone to college right yeah what's the
[ __ ] difference none what's the
[ __ ] difference so you're 16 now you
[ __ ] quit
you get a job with your father for two
[ __ ] years you put away money you get
your ged when you're 18 you go to the
community college and after two years
you transfer into a major [ __ ]
college how's that one for you
they'll give you more of an odd because
you had a problem and i quit you make up
some [ __ ] story that your foot went
bad you got you stepped on a [ __ ]
grenade or something isisville whatever
the [ __ ] you gonna tell them and uh
it's so weird how all these things i say
to you like
the organization i didn't know nothing
about this [ __ ] you learned this along
the way
yeah but
was it hard for you to break bad habits
because that's what you know what breaks
bad habits two things losing money
breaks bad habits
and losing things
like if you come to me and i don't have
the paperwork on you
like the first year i did the podcast i
would always get mad because i would
always read the [ __ ] things three
times a week but i never bothered to
look at the ios right i never bought to
look at the dates on them i just take
them for granted there was two or three
times a month and then i get pissed off
when they pay me for one time i go well
what about look at the il
oh
i never took the time to look for io so
what happened i lost money
that's how you learn you learn by
getting kicked in the [ __ ] ass but
but at that time at that point sometimes
it's too late
like that's that's like everyone always
says you learn from failures that
doesn't help someone who's like not not
mad at you but everyone says it like
everyone says that as you're getting
into an entrepreneurial thing and you're
like i don't wanna first of all stop
saying entrepreneur whatever the word is
stop starting a business stop saying
that [ __ ] [ __ ] american word that
just makes you stand out like a [ __ ]
momo i'm an entrepreneur go [ __ ] your
mother we're all do everywhere
somebody's got to be helping us
right you know what i'm saying so
you want to go into business for
yourself right yeah so you just got to
step up to the [ __ ] pump
i've been in business for myself for 30
[ __ ] years 25 doing comedy let's just
say 25. right well okay so just
for your thing since you said you you uh
went back and forth when you were
starting comedy like before you really
jumped into it do you think that time
period was your
not being sure like being nervous about
jumping into
okay i was talking to tommy easter today
my brother tommy
and we're talking about a delicate
subject about him getting a job and why
it's important
and i explained to him when i moved here
i thought it was johnny bananas too
and i eventually got a job you know
people say oh artists don't get jobs
that's great
that's [ __ ] great not when you got a
coke habit and you got child support and
you're [ __ ] trying to live on
people's couches and you want to buy a
pair of pants and [ __ ] ross you know
when you want to do all these things you
need a [ __ ] job right okay right now
if i took tom east on the road
four times a [ __ ] month what would he
make
what would he make if i play if i pay
for the plane ticket he'd make 200 a
week at the club if i threw him an extra
100 it cost him [ __ ] they got he get
he get uh
300 a week that's 1200 a [ __ ] month
he's going to eat 150 while he's on on
the road
you know what i'm saying so you can't
make a living you can't live on 1200 you
can't make a living you can't make it
unless you come back and you got 100
gigs during the week because you have to
store the improv you see what they give
you at the improv a seven dollar bill
they give you a five and two singles at
the [ __ ] comedy store they give you
15 bucks and at the laugh fracture they
give you 25 but you get the check every
[ __ ] two weeks so let's say you do
four spots that means you pick up 100
[ __ ] dollars okay
you can't make a living right now at
this situation you can't get ahead you
can't put away money so i told my go to
one of those telemarketing places they
pay 15 bucks an hour on sunset inbound
[ __ ] calls people put ads out in the
paper
whatever and you call this [ __ ]
number for a couch or you know when you
call the sleep manic bed you watch tv
and they have the sleep matic bed right
follow us right now in the next 20
seconds what do you think you call uncle
joey hi how are you i'm a sleep manic
professional i'm some [ __ ] junkie who
can't sleep at night that's gonna answer
the phone for [ __ ] 12.50 an hour
and trying to sell you a [ __ ] bed
so i explained to him that there's no
stigma in this
that right now at this point in his life
he's living in a van
how long he would have to go on the road
for three months and not spend the time
to get into a [ __ ] apartment
uh okay not spend the time to get to an
apartment in this town and like i told
him i go you're not getting into the taj
mahal what you're gonna do is get a job
there's a plan and this is the same plan
i had my plan was cut short when my
vehicle was towed
you understand me so now i had to think
a little quicker thank god i had people
like ralphie may and josh wolfe that i
could sleep on their couch i always
threw him a couple bucks i almost i
always help them out you show up with a
little [ __ ] weed
and everybody helps each other out
but i moved them with gavin
and i had to give gavin rent money and
it was a couch
i had that because it was a couch and a
shower
wasn't the best sleep in the world i
didn't sleep comfortable wasn't great
for my lumbar
but the [ __ ] options were the street
so it makes your lumbar wakes up [ __ ]
perfect you wake up in tip-top and goose
shape and [ __ ] yeah
and then well this is
get a roommate situation
and then after that you meet a girl and
you you date and you have a roommate
situation you move in together you save
money and all along the way
you're making little [ __ ] strides but
you don't even know it
you know like i told him i go if you
stay out there one more year you're
gonna go home
you're gonna go home you can only live
in a [ __ ] car for so long
before it starts to bother you you know
nobody wants to hire you
you pulled up in your [ __ ] apartment
it smells like a shoe in there you know
there's vomit
there's foot and i'm not saying nothing
bad about tommy i lived in that car also
i lived in my car so i'm speaking from
[ __ ] experience here
so there's things that you don't want to
do
but you learn how to
adjust
you're going to learn along the way lee
but for you to always want to fall
with somebody a part of a team what team
are you [ __ ] talking about what team
are you experiencing what team do you
know
that you want to be a part of three
white dudes that think they're all
geniuses
and they haven't done deck right they
haven't done deck
they haven't done deck you've been here
since day one you came to me for [ __ ]
three months ago you can't you just
start your own podcast
you should really start your own podcast
you've been here since day one
nine offices
18 different conglomerations computers
wiring cds
boxes
live podcast podcast at a coffee shop
you want to name a [ __ ] few so all
these things
they haven't done all these [ __ ]
things so what are they going to say to
you at a meeting when you're sitting
there stuttering and sweating and all
red from the [ __ ] head they're
talking nonsense they don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about how long
will that last what team are you a part
of
right but then that's what i'm worried
about though is like i'm not
a good salesman i'm not that's not my
strength you're a jew it's in your
[ __ ] dna you just gotta wake it up
remember you said you went to israel
right that the people there would be
tremendous salesmen here that they
didn't stop in the street tell them what
they did to you they took your wallet
they take your id yeah they took your
wallet they don't they don't stop
you know what man that type of
persistence
is
the persistence you need to succeed
if you really think about it like i'm i
need to eat today this [ __ ] is
coming in here with money in this pocket
and i'm getting it
think of that mindset
because that's a mindset you have when
you sell cars or vacuums
for you to be really [ __ ] successful
okay i learned
when i worked in boulder okay when i
learned
this is a great story because
the guy's a [ __ ] animal
when i worked in boulder i worked with
pure [ __ ] sales machines
normal led carlos valverde these guys
could sell you anything
it could be a refrigerator a computer
i saw it
marty sadler he's a frontier honda now
he's a general manager
that guy can sell you anything
to anybody to anybody bump you
make you believe you're paying nothing
he's not making a profit
on the way back to the tower he's like
go do your paperwork you're getting 500
for this plus the five sp splitter with
me for 250. and you're like i thought
you didn't make no money on this that's
how good these guys are
okay but there was a guy by the name of
rick visser
didn't say much white dude
hair on the side buck teeth
six foot four two daughters
was an engineer or something
an architect and lost his job at ibm one
of those [ __ ] heartbreak stories from
30 years ago jesus yeah all those
computer plans closed down
he became a subaru car salesman
but he was different
he
wouldn't beat people up
he was a gentleman he would talk to them
he would take their information their
phone number and mail them stuff and
brochures and
he had a different way of selling you
okay
normally is gone he's probably [ __ ]
80 and with a bad kidney carlos valverde
he's probably getting out of jail
i'm sitting here with you right now
talking [ __ ] you know what rick this is
doing
what
he's still selling subaru's he works by
appointment only
two days a week he's a painter
he paints pictures and sells them
and he probably makes 300 000 a year
selling cars selling cars
while everybody else is making a hundred
and fifty
working like a dog rick visser works two
days a week by appointment only
so people will call him when they just
want to re-up their
he treated you
like you've never been treated before
once rick vista took your name down
you went through an array of systems
when nobody was using the computer he
was using a computer you got birthday
stuff christmas card sent to you your
daughter's birthdays he knew everything
about you
he he just didn't sell you one car
he was gonna sell you cars
your kid car
your daughter a car her boyfriend i mean
it's amazing
i look at that and i think about that
all the time
right yeah okay how
these other guys
were
great cells in their own right
but they were only a part of the small
picture
you know when these guys
went to lunch and had a drink rick vista
was filling up
postcards
you know rick visser would come in at 7
30 when everybody came in at nine
because he talked to the service
customers
okay what did he jesus christ you know
what i'm saying dog
so
he worked smarter
okay all the way through
because while he while you got him for
five thousand dollars and you robbed the
poor bastard of his car
you're never gonna sell him another car
rick fist is gonna sell that guy
30 [ __ ] cars in his lifetime
and he'll just call him and make an
appointment but do you know why
he wasn't a great salesman
he was great with paperwork and
follow-up
and he wasn't scared to call you
that's a good point so you don't have to
be like
the prototypical anything you just have
to find a way to make it work for you
that's a good way to make it work for
you
everybody's different
i don't ever want you know what happens
when you're part of a team but
it gives you a little competition you
know what competition's great for you
but sometimes it's bad for you at a
certain age
i don't want to worry about what these
don't the only person i worry about is
what joey diaz is doing right that's it
and and if you worry about what joey
diaz is doing
like if i worry about it
i can see i'll make strides
with my life you know what i'm saying
like i could see the strides when i
first moved here jesus christ this guy
got a deal this guy got that this guy
got that i was always thinking about
what i wasn't getting yeah and i was
thinking about these guys what they
would get when i stopped thinking about
what they were getting then i started
getting stuff
did you have to stop this word you keep
throwing at me entrepreneur right is
about state of mind
and work
and sticking
to it
consistency yeah that's that's where i
have issues
that
is the number one thing
that
will always kill you
that if i watched all the great comics
that i came up with they were always
very consistent when i was inconsistent
i didn't have anything going on for
myself
all the comics that were consistent
they work forever they do this forever
if i tell you i'm gonna do something
every monday at eight
we do it
you know
there's a lot of times i don't [ __ ]
feel like my wife is sick tonight we
couldn't have done this tonight we could
have came tomorrow friday who gives a
[ __ ] mainly
just a podcast
and then when it fails
you're mad at the podcast business right
you know i'm saying oh it's a podcast
business it's a [ __ ] racket no he
didn't put your thyme
into it you went away from consistency
is everything
i have a big problem i'm too consistent
how can you be too concerned do
consistently i really don't give a [ __ ]
what plans you have
yeah
i really don't give a [ __ ] about your
plans
when i came to los angeles i knew i was
going into a
major league and i could look here
straight in the face and i could sit on
this goddamn podcast
i didn't become a major league [ __ ]
comedian until six years ago
i can't imagine how on major league i
was
when i first [ __ ] got here
but i did something i stuck to my guns
on one thing
and that's one thing i stuck to my until
today
i do what i do
and i do it
and that's it i don't give a [ __ ] about
what your problem is i don't give a [ __ ]
about what your situation is
i don't give a [ __ ] about what you want
to do i don't give a [ __ ] about your
movie
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything i
always that was the greatest quality i
had
not giving a [ __ ] no when i get up in
the morning i have a schedule
and unless
i don't break that [ __ ] schedule
i don't break it
i don't give a [ __ ]
you know people offer me [ __ ] all the
time now but it's tuesday in new york
i gotta do a podcast
i don't give a [ __ ]
you know i got into comedy part of it
not to have to go to weddings and
stupidity on the weekends
that's
sixty percent of them sixty percent only
why i got enough girls
no because i i wanted to be busy i
didn't want to have time for [ __ ]
stupidity in my life right yeah or what
i thought was stupidity for somebody
else going to weddings
it's probably a lot of fun you know what
i'm saying are you ready for another
dosely
it's that type of night i want to say it
doesn't look like i have a choice this
is bleeding thc right now
mm-hmm
consistency
is so [ __ ] important
so [ __ ] important it it kills you
and i saw it kill people in comedy and
that's what made me even more consistent
how did it kill people holly howard
being inconsistent kill people
right now i got a bad back
and for the last three weeks i've had a
bad back
and i can't go to jiu-jitsu it makes me
very inconsistent
but it's a true injury that i have you
know i'm also thinking if i was your age
i'd be down there
with nothing going on i'd be down to but
right now i think of the baby i think
i'm on stage i can't go on stage [ __ ]
walking all crooked because i'm a bad
back
because i want to go to jiu jitsu or do
kettlebells or do dead lifts or whatever
the [ __ ] i want you following me is all
these [ __ ] things
your responsibilities i sat here over
the years and watched different
comedians
and watched different people who said
they were writers
and they and i watched their boudoir
lifestyle
and i would go i wouldn't do that move
but that's just me i would never repeat
to them that i wouldn't do it what were
they doing
in this whole
six weeks of [ __ ] going on the road
and stuff i great i gained three pounds
nice that's it that was really good i
was really impressed with that when i
went to the doctor that morning
and it was your 303 i was like what
with the [ __ ] i went to new york the
cuban steak sandwich and everything
but i didn't eat sweets like i just
didn't need sweets okay okay and i
stayed pretty consistent
and you you were walking and i was
walking i always do something i'm always
doing [ __ ] something
but
with a diet people always got a diet
didn't work for me but now you didn't
let the [ __ ] diet work for you
you know weight watchers is [ __ ] a
great diet i don't give a [ __ ] about
people tight
it took a hundred pounds off me and that
[ __ ] like that one egg with an english
muffin
with two pieces of bacon and water you
know all that [ __ ] it taught me that i
didn't need french fries it taught me
that any chips
you know that you didn't have them you
have a point system if you stick to this
[ __ ] point system the [ __ ] will fall
off it took about four weeks for chunks
to start falling off you know what i'm
saying so i could see where people get
uh
discouraged right hell yeah but the same
thing happens with comedy
when you you have different parts of
your career
and there's different things going on
when there's different parts of your
career like tommy easton tommy easton
will be busy as [ __ ]
from sunday to thursdays
but friday and saturday this becomes a
different town it's a showcase town
so at that level you're really not busy
unless you're a feature act and you're
opening up for somebody in [ __ ] nice
house
you understand i'm talking about even at
the improv they have three man x
so it's kind of rough when you live in
seattle or michigan or dc
when you're an open micro you have all
this work during the week but on fridays
and saturday prime nights you're open
you can get a job bartender and then
once you start getting weekend work
you get rid of that work so pretty much
during the week you work for free and on
the weekends you get paid for your
[ __ ] work
oh god you would just bartend on the
weekends i wouldn't bartend that i'm
just saying you would i didn't know even
to get a job but not to get a job that's
how stupid i was
but if you think now in hindsight every
level along the way and then came a
point where i was just working weekends
and during the weekend you picked up one
night for a buck and a quarter or 75
bucks or 65 bucks or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
and that all adds in to your monthly
[ __ ] spew you know
absolutely yeah it's tough
listen when you're talking about being
scared here okay the biggest fear
the reason why guys like me and other
guys
okay so let's say tomorrow i want to
sell real estate
okay right yeah now for the last six
years i've been uh
let's give me a fake occupation i've
been selling reefer
at that
medical marijuana store
i get 12 bucks an hour i work full-time
you know i'm single i smoke dope i go to
the gym i go to concerts [ __ ] like that
right okay now comes one day that my mom
had one of those stupid holidays sits me
down and gives me a beating
joey you're not a kid no more you gotta
think of something serious
why don't you go sell real estate with
your cousin lee you know what do you
think happens when you sell real estate
the first six months
not much you're probably not so you're
now when you sell real estate which
means you go to work for yourself right
yeah which means you're uh entrepreneur
whatever that [ __ ] word is
correct yeah it's the same thing
now with those jobs they give you like a
base salary
like 500 a month
during training for six months you know
what 500 a month does for you nothing
those are those lunches gasoline and
your dry cleaning bill yeah yeah so how
are you gonna make a living
you have to do something else you gotta
do something else or you gotta sell
[ __ ] oh yeah so what happens you get
your license
after the first month you [ __ ] around
how many people you know
tomorrow check the stats on real estate
licenses yeah compared to how many
people are really [ __ ] selling real
estate
it's crazy everybody's got a real estate
license
right any [ __ ] [ __ ] with a fork a
four-door car and a nice suit could sell
[ __ ] real estate i'm not calling you
a [ __ ] i'm just telling you that's how
simple it is right because i know a
thousand people are real estate licenses
but the people actually do it what
happens you get a real estate license
okay you go to work for smith and smith
selling homes
you show three or four homes
it doesn't work out it's a long it's a
90-day [ __ ] paperwork you gotta do
paperwork nobody just comes in and goes
i'll buy this house today here's an
envelope full of cash right yeah and the
next day you get a [ __ ] commission
has to go through banks and so even if
you start selling right off the [ __ ]
back like let's say now you're moving
with paula
and paul is gets an attorney job and off
the bat she makes 60 grand a year you
tell paul to paul listen when we started
dating and you were going to law school
i was paying for all those cheeseburgers
and [ __ ]
now you got to take care lee
i gotta take care of you so for a year
lee you're gonna go out every day
you know
if you don't sell them for two months
what are you gonna do you're gonna get a
[ __ ] job
and then you're gonna get that job until
it takes over your real estate
and then you're never gonna sell real
estate again and you're gonna have the
excuse that
four out of [ __ ] ten people have six
out of ten people it was too hard
nobody's buying no you didn't you didn't
rick viscera
you didn't a dedicate yourself to it you
know the reason why comedians get an
outside job
was because i didn't dedicate myself to
it you know that much like that but
there's only so much you could do in the
beginning
you know he's been doing comedy for what
four years he said tell me tell me you
think it's like two years yeah i was
doing comedy for six years here
you know not that in la when i got here
i was doing college for maybe five six
seven years six years okay when i
basically got here i was lost
but i booked commercials and that's what
i told tommy easter today you'll get
yourself a headshot for book 50
and go
and they'll they'll take any lee if you
walked in with a head shot tomorrow
that's halfway decent and said you do
stand up comedy
any of these agents in the valley will
take you as a commercial client
really yep
they have nothing to lose
you're non-union
they have nothing to lose
[ __ ]
yeah why not
but but now let's say you go to three
auditions and you don't get something
[ __ ] this sucks
and you got a job painting houses and i
come up to you how was the commercial
audition now you know what i did i went
to commercial classes
i never really took a commercial acting
class i'm lying to you but i took acting
classes
after i went to a couple of them and
failed i went to an acting class and got
serious about it
and that's when i started making money
yeah so but how do you because i it was
in uh really interesting a few minutes
ago when you're saying make it work for
you so how do you make like acting work
for you
okay if you're if you're 26 27 right now
and you live in this [ __ ] town right
there's a lot of work for you okay and
if you're non-union there's a lot of
work for you
okay because they're shooting a lot of
non-union [ __ ]
the kid from the ice house the bald
headed kid with the dog that we see
walking around and lives across the
street there he's on fire right now
he hasn't stopped working
he shot masters of the universe
something else
something else something else
right now there's a lot of work from
there's a lot of work for that age
bracket you know that's an interesting
age bracket you know how many mafia
movies they make a year
two how many times they're going to call
me to be a garbage man or something like
that then i'm really
unless somebody sees me as a co-star or
somebody's [ __ ] sidekick i get dick
but a good looking 28 years old with a
nice body and [ __ ] right now you're
getting work brother you know so you got
two options
you could either be one of those [ __ ]
morons
that goes to the standard every night
and talks about his scenes
or you could be the guy that stays in
every night
and goes over movies
and goes to acting class once a week or
twice a week and learns his trade and
just learns how to [ __ ] work okay
how do you get to work lee i drive no
you [ __ ] momo how do you get to work
how do you get things in motion okay oh
okay how do you get things in motion
there's no emotion going on in your life
right now right you know what i think i
want to do podcasts
you find that you come into the comedy
store you come up to joey diaz and you
go hey man
you think i could come in and sit down
with you guys one day i mean i'm gonna
say no you're a [ __ ] lunatic but you
never know you never know who you speak
to you know cassius morris you may talk
to tom segura you may talk to somebody
okay and what do you do you come in here
for a few weeks
and you shut up and then we like you and
you go listen what if i brought a
[ __ ] 20 dollar bag of weed you might
guys mind if i come here on
mondays and wednesdays to sit here with
you
and eventually one day you're going to
say something funny we're going to give
you a mic
then you're going to keep coming you're
going to keep coming
you're going to keep saying funny as
[ __ ] you learn when to talk and when not
to talk
you're not going to be obnoxious and you
know what one day we're going to go just
sit in it
and there you have it and after six
months nine months
somebody comes to go dog
i'm gonna give you like [ __ ] 300 a
week to come in here twice a week
and all of a sudden you made yourself
part of something right
you know what i'm saying like i learned
if you want a job
when i was your age if i wanted a job in
construction
you went over this let me work for free
for a day
if you don't like how i work don't pay
me and don't hire me i'll go home my
feelings won't be hurt
and you work
some people do it for a [ __ ] week
[ __ ] that not a lot of people you know
how many how many [ __ ] if you let
this town in turn you to death right how
many [ __ ]
places do you think i guarantee there's
places that'll make you work like a
[ __ ] slave
and call you a [ __ ] intern yeah
that's the whole you know i'm [ __ ]
not lying no that's the whole point
that's the whole [ __ ] and they'll do it
with no future like there's no way i'm
giving you a job i'm not even the budget
you'll never be in the budget right
but don't make you come in here and just
do it you know what but there's a way
you get a job at that place
if you work harder than the other guy if
you do more than that [ __ ] well you
pick a guy in that office and go you
know what
i ain't this guy i ain't this guy this
guy but i can [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
right here
watch me go to work [ __ ]
then you earn the job
yeah yeah i mean
you have to be
good but like
like i just meant like
[ __ ] that's
never mind i was high for a second
that's that's [ __ ] up working for free
though i don't like when you
do do you think people would still do
that
[ __ ] yeah especially in this industry
especially this [ __ ] list i worked on
movies where the [ __ ] uh camera guys
and [ __ ] are free the the helpers that's
true learning the [ __ ] trade learning
and you look and go jesus christ
but they love it
if this is what you want to do
if you want to be that director if you
want to be that type lighting guy if you
want to be that type that
top editor
obviously that's what you got to [ __ ]
dooley
because if that's a desire you have
you'll do it
right yeah when i mean when i came here
i was working for free all over the
place
but that but then it's hard
for my like my type of personality going
back to making it work for you
i i don't i would get nervous about
going to the places where i work for
free and now asking for money like it's
hard like that's a [ __ ] up situation
to be in
well
before you do it
there also has to be
there's ways to do it
i mean there's ways to do it
and there's ways to come into a place
i use the podcast places like a radio
place
i knew a lot of guys that got into radio
by just showing up at a radio station
somebody inviting them in
and them going and sitting and sitting
and sitting and one day while i'm
talking they write something on a piece
of paper and give it to you
and another week they write something
again that's pretty interesting what
this guy writes on a piece of paper
eventually
boom you know john cutler is a friend of
mine him and amy on facebook and twitter
john sends me messages and [ __ ]
sometimes when he sends him from his
hotmail they go directly he sends them
from this [ __ ] phone number they go
through uh that [ __ ]
facebook or something yeah no when you
send the [ __ ] thing to my email
from a phone number oh right right he
goes into junk for some [ __ ] so i don't
see him until like a year later
but it's funny he told me a story about
how he met jerry garcia
from the grateful dead
that he went to see a gig and he saw
jerry walk and he goes hey this thing
that you have didn't sound right tonight
because it didn't because yeah come on
let's go take a look at it
it's like if i bump into you down the
stream or you listen to the podcast
tonight something's wrong with the
volume and i go let's go take a look at
it
and all of a sudden they became friends
you know they started showing up and
tuning his guitars and blah blah blah
blah blah blah
and one [ __ ] day he's uh he i think
he's a producer and touching gray or
something holy [ __ ]
yeah just being being there because
that's the problem with a lot of job uh
postings online you always hear people
like i don't think my resume is getting
seen so like that's if you're if you're
there we've talked about it before but
that's the issue
it's uh
you have to create opportunities for
yourself and i haven't answered your
question i have not answered your
question about the
you have what it takes lee to go out
there and start this podcast name
it's going to be a little sacrifice
it's going to be a little bit of work
you know
um
but you could pull this off
the idea we discussed
i think this could franchise
like as dumb as
i've been listening okay we were talking
about something a while ago
20 years ago
when we were talking about boston market
right yeah the lines around boston
market
there was 3 000 boston markets correct
yeah i don't know what the amount was
i'm gonna be exaggerating
and all of a sudden after the chicken
crazy after the chicken after the 14
chicken friends he went over
because pretty soon supermarkets were
like 14 for a chicken
we'll sell these [ __ ] for six
and that was the end of the boston
market people said no more about boston
market with 14
because i first bought the market would
hit you and everybody was like the
chicken's delicious
then once they everybody caught on then
they started giving you those chickens
they get kicked and they kick him in the
head and [ __ ] those chickens now
horrible you go to boston market now
that chicken's depressed as [ __ ] i
haven't been in years oh i gotta go
every [ __ ] friday if i'm in town
because mercy likes this she likes the
mac and cheese from there she likes the
whole experience
she kicks the [ __ ] door
the whole thing so i get stuck with that
[ __ ] uh
chicken cutlets or the chicken or the
meat and the meatloaf i had to stop
eating yeah that's cause that's just the
horror show the [ __ ] pork ribs i was
even i even pulled the lead and ordered
the pork ribs one night and i took a
bite of them and then something made me
turn them over and it looked like
somebody spray painted them and i was
like that's it i ain't eating this [ __ ]
no more i'm surprised you let her eat
the mac and cheese that's my like my
least favorite mac and cheese hey listen
i don't even like [ __ ] mac and cheese
how old are we now after you're [ __ ]
20 you don't eat mac and cheese no more
unless now they got like lobster mac and
cheese and you go out to your friends
and they dope it up but you're not gonna
eat mac and cheese out of a box i hope
not with that stu god's chatter [ __ ]
thing i'd rather eat that than the
boston market mac and cheese listen i'd
rather not eat none of them
brother why can't you avoid all that
cancer you haven't had mac and cheese
for a while i can just tell yeah look at
that i can tell you're sad about it i am
i like that purple box auntie anne's
the whatever um
no your whole [ __ ] entrepreneurship
has got to just go for it
go for it cut this [ __ ] and go for it
[ __ ] yeah i know you first of all you're
gonna spend eighty-two thousand dollars
too much yep okay you're gonna go to
these places and say hey you need foot
track right now what you need is half
and half
because you don't need for traffic
who's going to be walking down the
street going oh my god i'm in the mood
to do a podcast right yeah oh well
yeah you're right and it's just it's
just a lot of my it's money like you we
were talking a while ago and i was
getting too shark tank and i was like
percentages and and i have to write a
business but like it's just it's uh
it's something that i've never done
before so i'm scared and i don't i don't
run towards it like you do i run away
from it so it's just i went to a meeting
yesterday
and we got to pitch something okay and
i've been i've known this kid for a
while he's a kid from newark very
interesting kid
and uh our buddy matt lammon was there
you know matt lam is an interesting cat
and i guess two guys from matt lahmann's
office were there you know the other two
guys are very nice guys we were talking
and it's weird when
you're trying to sell a show
okay because every show and movie you
watch
starts a certain way
but then they do things to it to make it
sellable right absolutely to make it
into a movie like if you go into like
when whenever i watch the the one with
leonardo dicaprio
and he plays with jack nicholson the
departed
oh yeah i always think that girl was
just put in there for a reason like
after the movie was written they put her
in there for a love interest there
always has to be a love interest you
know in today's uh television world now
they're talking about
uh
you have to have enough black people
you have to have enough spanish people
you have to have enough asian people on
the show
so if you have to have 12 people on a
show it has to break down
so it's watchable by the network
standards did you know that
so if you come in and lease white by the
end of the [ __ ] pilot lee might be
[ __ ] hindu
because they need a certain amount of
indians
need diversity to make a show work
which i don't like i think the show
should come out the way you want to
[ __ ] write it
you know what i'm saying i could care
less about the other [ __ ] if it calls
for a black guy then put the [ __ ]
black guy in if you grew up in an
armenian then write the [ __ ]
character armenian that's what i feel
but yeah but they with movies with
everything in this town they just right
but they always have to have a female
[ __ ] thing in there the whole thing
the love story
and sometimes it's great but sometimes
it [ __ ] ruins it i don't know what my
point was what was the [ __ ] point of
this box i'm not to be honest we have to
after that last edible knock lecture
yeah i don't [ __ ] know but
you always have to dress something up to
sell it right absolutely oh yeah we're
selling a show and it's crazy that these
two guys are a lot more experienced than
anybody everybody else at the table
and they were making uh
ideas and their ideas were great
but i always knew
to sell this particular show that these
gentlemen wanted to sell
it was more of a character driven show
this shows it would be sold by the
friends to this [ __ ] guy
and the characters in his world his
character the characters in this guy's
world are beautiful
at the end we asked for notes and that's
the note they gave us
the characters
and on the way home i thought about
instincts
like
sometimes you write stuff as a writer
but sometimes i do stuff by instincts
and sometimes instincts is a lot better
you know let your instincts be natural
with whatever [ __ ] thing you want to
do think it over
i gotta be honest with you i was
watching the show named celia on netflix
okay about celia cruz it's 80 episodes
not the best television i've ever seen
in my life it's not
academy award-winning but it's got to do
with cuban stuff so if i'm not just
sitting there
this week i've just been trying to take
the [ __ ] out of my head you know what
i'm saying trying to take the old jokes
out of my head the old way of thinking
oh interesting so i just want to be a
family this week this week i just wanted
to
not do anything
sometimes it caught your time you like i
wouldn't think this way when i was your
age
because i always thought i had to get
ahead and kill somebody but now
for me to like you know listen bro this
started in july and then we had the move
and then we had the [ __ ] jiu jitsu
the blue belt and then we had the
[ __ ]
you know mercy with this and then we had
melrose
austin
new york
oddball
columbus and chicago you know it's just
a lot of [ __ ] happened that was six
weeks of planes there was a lot of [ __ ]
happening lee
and i knew
two weeks ago i said once the special's
done i'm done
i'm done for five days what does that
mean that's why i went to the doctor
with my wife you think i want to go to
the doctor with my wife
are you [ __ ] crazy are you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but every time i go to the doctor my
wife is like i don't know not real like
when i go to get blood donation she
doesn't go on me
but for the surgeries and stuff my wife
is there you know even though she made
plans she'll go no i wanted to be here
with you
so i went with it today and we went and
got i don't know something to eat after
i don't even know what the [ __ ] we went
we got a muffin and a coffee or
something we would have gotta
to look at a ah where the [ __ ] did we go
we went somewhere
and then we just went home
and now we went to jerry's deli oh no i
got the chicken soup you know the
chicken soup when you're sick of all
soup yeah and i got the chicken and rice
and it was [ __ ] like you want to get
a sandwich then you're going to know
that really after i went there with you
that time i was like i'm not getting no
[ __ ] sandwich here so i just had the
bowl of soup and we both went home went
to sleep i took the the whatever tammy
flew and i took a [ __ ] nap too
and on the way i go why did i go with my
wife today i could have wrote for two
hours no i needed to do that i needed to
get back to normal i'm a family guy
i'm a part of a family and i'm not only
a stand-up comedian
so anyway back to [ __ ] celia i'm
watching the cellular thing about this
cuban girl they're talking about dreams
what's her dream and this is opportunity
she goes to see this band
and the singer of the band who's a
popular woman a puerto rican woman in a
band in cuba the populist the biggest
band in cuba okay that same night she
finds out she's pregnant
so you already see where the story was
going celery crew's a tremendous [ __ ]
singer the only reason they won't let
her sing is because he's dark-skinned
really oh yeah cuban was very racist in
the 50s and [ __ ] they're more racist
than here those [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah cubans are racist
[ __ ] dog
so uh
she kept talking about a dream and i'm
like what you know yeah i've had dreams
before my dreams are completely
unfucking
you know when i was a kid my dreams were
just stupid like stupid why why were
they stupid because i just wanted to be
a nothing i wanted to end up being a
dude who bought people drinks and pulled
up with a maserati and he was a cool
dude
that's garbage i didn't want to be an
astronaut a construction guy and then
i wanted to be like johnny holly with a
son for years until i went to jail and
that jolly hot
to the
challenge the johnny hollywood image
faded [ __ ] fast you know
but uh they're talking about dreams and
[ __ ] sometimes everything happens
fast
you know different opportunities you're
there at the right place at the right
time you want to you and i were there at
the right place at the right time yeah
absolutely i got a camera from [ __ ]
gabriel you contacted me we took films
everything worked out very organically
you did it all the right way you had all
the right
instincts so
go with it again don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] stop thinking about [ __ ] but
i want you to think about that
okay if you and this is the most
important thing that people don't do
i want you to break it down from east to
west and north to south
even if you have to get a notebook to
break it down as dumb and coked out as i
was in 1995 it's called it
it's called like a jefferson clothes or
a jackson clothes or a lincoln clothes
somebody's going to correct me on this
will you take a sheet of paper or
washington clothes okay you take a sheet
of paper you put a line right down the
sheet of paper okay and you write down
the positive and the negative and you
take that situation and you write down
the positive when you write down the
negative then you look at them together
and that's what i did before before i
left jackie
like
after i went to court in 1995 i went at
it with my wife in court and we yelled
at each other the whole way to the car
when i then you know i actually smacked
the [ __ ] guy and then
two weeks later i'm in my [ __ ]
apartment thinking you know where the
[ __ ] am i going with my life
what am i doing
i'm arguing with these people to see a
[ __ ] four-year-old kid that at the
end of the day
i'm her father but i have nothing to
offer
except love and bad [ __ ] advice at
this point in my life
that's all i had to offer and i had to
be honest that's the most important
thing about those things with the piece
of paper
that you have to write them write it
down honestly so you could see it and
see how it affects you then a thought
and a piece of paper
a written thing on a piece of paper and
a thought is two different things lee
when i write when i tell you a story
after i kid in that bell and we giggle
here and you think it's cute it's cute
when i write that story down and hand to
you and read it and you read it it's
going to hit you a little differently
it's going to hit you a little
differently you know what i'm saying
absolutely it's going to hit you
differently [ __ ]
how hard is it but
some people like to have inflated views
of themselves
if you're doing a prolonged calmness
like if you have an inflated view of
yourself or you have an unrealistic
[ __ ] view of yourself this is not
gonna work because you're never gonna
write the truth on that piece of paper
but do you think those people know like
what if i haven't everybody knows
everybody [ __ ] knows you know your
shortcomings and you know what you excel
at
everybody [ __ ] knows their
shortcomings everybody you know if you
got a ninja dick okay
only three chicks might know but you
know that you got an inch dick let's
keep it do you tell people no you don't
[ __ ] tell nobody okay it's the same
way with our shortcomings and we all
know what your [ __ ] shortcomings are
that's what pisses me off the most about
this
that every [ __ ] step along the way i
looked at myself in that [ __ ] mirror
whether it was coked up or not and go
this is what i got going on this is what
i don't have going on
now what are we gonna do to have it
going on
with the little we have going on
yeah [ __ ] you do you follow me and i
still do this [ __ ]
i still do this [ __ ]
you know when i talk to somebody about
management for example and i tell them
listen this is not to be me calling you
up telling you i want to be on letterman
or leno or
kimble i'm sorry or [ __ ] the other
dude
this is not joey d is calling you up
into one in the morning and saying hey
how come i don't have a show on hbo
because i understand that i'm not going
to do that to nobody
i'm going to hit you
with things that are realistic for my
realm
you know what i'm saying i'm never going
to call you if you call me and go shall
we
there's a new [ __ ] uh
will ferrell movie
and the guy opposite him has to be
italian but good looking
do you think i'm going to call i'm going
to try to get on that because i know i'm
good look i don't know i know i'm funny
i may not be good looking but the
good-looking guys you're looking at may
not be [ __ ] funny oh will farrell's
just insecure and he doesn't want
somebody really funny next to him
but either way i'm gonna [ __ ] give it
a shot
right
but so but you're not gonna you're not
gonna be
like upset if you don't like what are
you so what are you saying like that you
know
i'll never ask you for something outside
my realm okay
okay whether you're my manager and i'm
never gonna come to you and go listen i
want 13 episodes on abc about me [ __ ]
chicks in the ass that's not gonna work
i know that's a [ __ ] far fetch for
you i'll tell you what i do expect
pretty soon six episodes on a tv show as
a reoccurring [ __ ]
garbage man or a painter or something
that's not out of my realm i got the
resume to cover that do i not no you do
this okay okay that's what i'm saying to
you i've always been one of those guys
you know i could call my agents tomorrow
listen i wanna do a theater tour uh
joey about i'll cover it
i wanna do a 2 200 seat theater tour
excuse me in every [ __ ] city now i
know that's unrealistic and guess what i
wouldn't want to do it that's a lot of
[ __ ] work
but
i'm the type of guy that'll call you i
can handle [ __ ] six shows in jersey
bring it on
okay i'll never you know i know what i
can cover and what you can't cover
and that's the most important thing
about yourself in every [ __ ] level of
this game
as young comics
we'll say we could cover something even
if we can't cover it hey man i need a 20
minute spot you got 20 minutes uh yeah
you really got 12 and that's [ __ ]
stretching it that's talking like you're
half [ __ ] like you're hitting the
head with a brick my
name
is
lee
that's 12 minutes you know what i'm
saying right yeah and we all lie about
little things like that i lied about all
that [ __ ] yeah you got 20 minutes i got
20 minutes you only got [ __ ] 13.
and that's what a [ __ ] rock in your
pocket you'll have 20 if something
interesting happens or something like
that why are you looking at me like i
borrowed 20 bucks for me
maybe you did i don't know no
this is a does it i'm just trying to
relate back to what you said do you know
your uh shortcomings now because of
failures like because of saying yes when
you shouldn't have said yes listen man
by the time you're [ __ ] 25
you have a good idea you're not gonna
come to me and go joey you know what i'm
quitting the podcast game
to become an automobile mechanic
those will never come out of my mouth
no
no
but
you're going to say [ __ ] that you're
going to want to do when i was snoring
all that coke and [ __ ] and i was looking
for a [ __ ] life do you think i was
sitting there i gotta straighten out my
underwear okay do you think i was
[ __ ] sitting there
going i want to be a [ __ ] flight
attendant or something like that no do
you think i was telling people no
no
and that's the problem you have
especially here you have these people
coming to you i'm a director
not in my [ __ ] world you're not [ __ ]
not in my [ __ ] world you're not just
cause they sell a camera for 8.99 at
[ __ ] true value
doesn't mean you're a [ __ ] director
no let me see your [ __ ] work well i
did a flick in college and it won second
place
then me and my friend shot a short come
to me after you do four years behind
[ __ ] tarantino holding a wire
right so
yeah you have to have experience
absolutely
and it happens with everything it
happens with
with comedians who you've seen
like go up in and like
isn't that the thing people always get
mad at like tv sitcom actors forgot
trying to do stand-up
sometimes like
live guys or something trying to do
stand-up with them and doing improv and
they go and they listen man i'm real
proud i'm real proud of that guy from
[ __ ] those dudes that jumped off
buildings and [ __ ] oh stevo stevo's
still at it and he loves it he still
[ __ ] does shows and
you know you got to give him all the
respect in the world because he's stuck
with this wasn't a pipe dream from his
age and go hey if you need money put
together 45 minutes and go out there and
bore [ __ ] people to debt
and tell them about your [ __ ] uh how
much money you make and tell them about
your tv show and how you hate it working
with your co-star do that for 45 minutes
i'll get you 10 000 a week and they'll
do it for six weeks and you'll never
hear from them again
stevo at least stuck it out stevo was
the real dude got a showtime special and
everything he didn't [ __ ] around steven
so you gotta hand it to him there right
he's not it's not like the charlie sheen
tour that ended after like three weeks
yeah they're walking out
well you got the world by the balls and
everybody who listens to the show you
have the [ __ ] world by the balls and
a lot of us don't even know it i didn't
know it for a long time
for 10 years i walked around out here
not knowing what was going on i was
doing stand-up and i was doing some work
but i wasn't doing what i should have
been [ __ ] doing if i should have been
doing what i should have been doing you
and i would have been in a different
realm right now but you move on you live
and you [ __ ] learn yeah you know what
you you know what you're stronger
there's things i would never ask you to
do lee
there's things i would never ask you to
do but then like when we did the
documentary
i knew you could pull that off a [ __ ]
[ __ ] could it's not an academy award
winner we're not going for an academy
award with
we're just showing them little [ __ ]
scenes and you're an editor
you shoot the camera you press the
button
and you put it together
the best that you can do it
that's it i i knew you could do that
would we shoot a [ __ ] movie would i
use your [ __ ] no no yeah like if we
somebody gave us 300 thousand dollars
like oh at least science is going to
direct because he's the director from
israel no i'd be shooting myself in how
dare you you know i'd be giving you 10
grand right keeping 30 to make money on
the [ __ ] deal and the 40 should go to
a real [ __ ] director
absolutely you know and that's how i i
like to do it when i look at
whenever i do any of this dumb [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] just do it i go to the
expert and i learn how to [ __ ] to do it
i'll pay the [ __ ] ten dollars and
they teach you how to do this correctly
so i have to come back at this [ __ ]
later on
right if you don't do it right the
[ __ ] now then later on i could do
this this [ __ ] you could do with this
[ __ ] you can't do
i told you a thousand times today
i could quit [ __ ] comedy
right now quick comedy
quit this [ __ ]
podcast and go to a company and go
listen
i want your social media
and if your company does a podcast i
want to be a part of it
and this is what i can do this is how
i'm going to do it i can do that right
now with the experience i've gained the
last six years [ __ ] around with you
and social media
and itunes and learning the the [ __ ]
trends and when to tweet when not to
tweet i can do this right now oh
absolutely did somebody teach me this
[ __ ] no could somebody teach me this
[ __ ] no
i did it
you learned yourself i've learned my
trial and [ __ ] error
i learned doing little [ __ ] things
saying lewd things on twits and [ __ ]
like that
that nobody else is saying but guess
what they were looking at my twit stupid
and that's the point of this [ __ ]
game you dumb [ __ ]
so meanwhile you want to be joe
christian
with your safe little [ __ ] tweet you
ain't getting nowhere you can't get
nowhere
is that tweet where that when i put a
tweet out there about eating mrs obama's
[ __ ]
with that black ink out of her ass do
you think i mean that [ __ ]
no but it got your [ __ ]
attention the next tweet i put after
that you will see it
yeah absolutely you will see it that's
such a right hand over the top you will
see the photo that's such a great left
jab that you you'll see that right
coming over the [ __ ] top
so that's
that makes no sense you don't want to
see the right coming over the top but
you see it you know and i learned this i
think that people went to college for
four years
and are running these big corporations
would disagree with me
i beg to [ __ ] differ right now
if i had a product right now i'd be
having videos
i'd i'd pull my television budgeting to
half
and just go on a youtube interviewing
thing and hire great social media people
with my emphasis on instagram
and hire a comedic writer
to write on the tweet and spend that
money instead on that
to get business
anything
everybody's on the [ __ ] computer yeah
and with all the tv there is all the
real cool we speed through all that
commercial now commercials are dead
and tv knows this it's a matter of
[ __ ] years
it's dead but here's the [ __ ] up thing
we've we've been
praying for years for like pay by as you
go channels and now cbs and all those
people have pay as you go apps so we're
even they're getting i guarantee in a
few years they're gonna get rid of the
free like cbs and the nbc and all that
stuff
but it's uh
i think i think you could i think
there's a lot of people who have like
social media expert jobs now they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing no no
not a clue
i'll challenge them all because
what you could do on twitter is
completely different than what you do on
instagram or facebook it's all different
audiences
so
you're following me you could be a
little bit more risque with your product
on one than the other
and nobody would know the difference
people would say you see that ad for
[ __ ]
joey diaz's ball wash
let me give some [ __ ] shout outs here
paul lynch my man the la lingas family
out of chicago who i love uki spooky
will cook ray majewski
dante gazzini
that letter writing [ __ ]
savage
bobby and crystal the queen down there
in austin texas always and my main man
mikey stein
one by one podcast put shoot
[ __ ] down
one by one you know that word you use
entrepreneur
the reason why i [ __ ] hate that word
is because it scares people
okay
you know what entrepreneur means
just work hard for yourself
that's all that means
work hard for yourself
one of the most interesting [ __ ] guys
i met
out here
the last 10 years was a dude i don't see
no more his name was bob
and bob was a dude that was clean and
sober
but bob has an interesting [ __ ] story
okay
bob
was on drugs smoke crack
didn't have no teeth
you know
and i think when he was 50 he decided to
get his life together
and the rehab they put him in the the
program he got into
was like
an hour away from where he got a job so
he had to take a bus there
so he would take a bus every [ __ ] day
there
every day a bus there and back and he
went from making eight bucks an hour to
12
to 16 then it became a closer and it was
selling
duct tape
on the phone duct tape
and he became one of the top closers
forty thousand a year sixty thousand
here they gave his own office
you know it's like a rags-to-richer
story it gets better
he quit the [ __ ] company and he's
opened up his own tape company
in his garage in his 50s in his 50s by
this time he was like 57
58
and he was selling tape out of his
[ __ ] garage
on the phone just [ __ ] selling he's
in the truck maneuver right yeah
absolutely he got sick and tired for
working for somebody so he
he took his garage
and got a phone line out there and he
started calling people and sending boxes
out of there
he started doing so well and the
neighbors started complaining because of
all the
shipments of tape that he was getting
put with high lows and [ __ ] in front of
his house
for two or three days then getting sent
out
so he had no credit from all those years
of being a crackhole
so the landlord would only rent him the
space if he came up with 100 grand cash
like a certified check so he made a ten
thousand dollar deposit
and he told the guy he would be back in
90 days and for 90 days he made a
hundred [ __ ] grand
holy went back and he got into the
office for a [ __ ] year this little
warehouse
and then he went to work make a long
story short [ __ ] 3m bought them out
one of those tape companies bought them
out
and they gave him like six million
dollars eight million dollars i went to
his house they shot a movie up there
like a short film
and i played one of the guys that went
up there and the [ __ ] house is
beautiful
everything the guy had changed his life
he showed me all his [ __ ]
paperwork from all those years and stuff
from tape jesus duct tape
all right like he was an entrepreneur
you know so you do what you do and
you're handling
they just put such a big [ __ ] fear
into people yeah
that they can't do anything and you know
what you learn as you go along
and you make it work for you
this comedy [ __ ]
i went as i went along
and i learned from people like bobby
slate and jimmy schubert and joe rogue
carlos mencia
and i watched what they did on the road
i watch what gabriel does on the road
today
i watch what sebastian does on the road
and they all do something that works for
you and you take that ideology you know
what i'm saying right when i first met
rogan we all got on a plane there and we
all got on the plane back and that was
great
but one day i started thinking about it
i'm like first of all why are we going
into the night before
like we were let's say we had to be
there wednesday at eight for the first
show
we would leave here tuesday night at one
in the [ __ ] afternoon to get in there
at six for dinner
rent the car
that's another hour at the [ __ ]
airport get to the hotel with four of us
get upstairs you know it was just so
much [ __ ] and you don't know you're
just having a good time
but then you're like wait a second
something has to be done here
all right let's get rid of that tuesday
night flight
okay let's get rid of that tuesday night
flight
let's take the wednesday [ __ ] early
in the morning one more day at home
okay
we started taking that flight
that started working and then on sundays
instead of getting up at 10 hungover and
having a breakfast
and going to the airport at two
then your flight's delayed till 4 40
then you get into lax at [ __ ] eight
o'clock at night have you ever landed at
least 8 o'clock at night
jesus [ __ ] christ and your luggage
isn't coming for 45 [ __ ] minutes so
guess what that whole day of that day of
flying became the old day
one day you look at yourself and you
know you know what what happens if i
leave on the first flight
and you get the lax and it's 10 and it's
empty and there's cabs and people are
waving
and the 405 is empty
wow i just saved you know what i'm
saying lee
you just learned little tricks along the
way
for years they told you you got to stay
at that hotel there and it's 30 minutes
from the hotel from the club and one day
you realize [ __ ] you you're paying for
that hotel rate give me the rate let me
find my own hotel and there's a hotel
right around the corner from the club
that has breakfast in it for free and
they give you a shuttle ride to the
airport and you can walk to the comedy
club
you can leave the [ __ ] cop you can
leave your con you can leave the hotel
like quarter to [ __ ] eight and get to
the comedy club by ten to eight
you learn all these things
you learn all these things you learn
about you know how to make your life
easier we went on the flight last week
you know on the way down there the guy
made us pay for both luck he charged you
for your luggage now i'm platinum even
if i don't fly first class i get two
bags for free the chick charge you right
here she did on the way back
we both gave the guys the ids
and i gave him a 20 on the [ __ ] bill
and what did he do he turned he turned
it back he he [ __ ] no
he took your bag didn't charge us to 25
right yeah when he came back i said give
him the 20 difference
he would have made 40 on us and he'd
remember us forever he didn't take your
20. oh i didn't know you gave him 22.
the [ __ ] you think you're dealing oh
yeah he didn't take my 20. no i gave him
a 20 for me oh
but he i gave him a 20 for me and gave
both [ __ ] ids
ah
okay now you and paula would have walked
in and stood on line like mama luke's
for an hour and a half i think not just
security not anymore no now you see that
a 20 and that's it you move like a
[ __ ] soldier through that airport
you follow me
yeah did i know that when i was first
flying no i'd stand in the airport with
the other [ __ ] and tap my knees
against each other for the extra 20 you
[ __ ] go right at the gate and bam you
walk in like a doctor
and i bet there's a lot of people who
don't even pay the extra 20 for that
they probably stiff them no no there's a
lot of people giving five bucks or ten
that works too
but you know i want to there's a black
dude at kennedy airport that walks you
through security
did you know that he walks you past the
[ __ ] line is it to the front right
then he goes what's up jerry this is my
dog joey get in there
for 20 bucks that's all it costs is 20
bucks 20 bucks i would totally do that
he gets you checks your bag then goes
come on
and he walks you right to the front of
the [ __ ] line and he cuts everybody
off like a stewardess
you have been on the line in the [ __ ]
store this walks and she cuts right in
front of me oh yeah he cuts right in
front of me and do people get pissed off
at you who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] i'm walking in with
this six foot four [ __ ] black dude
what do you got to offer you know what
i'm saying remember when i cut the line
on the way to [ __ ] was it chicago i
think yeah you got right in the line
nobody said [ __ ] no they said something
they were selling the girl
the uh stewardess or the gate agent and
like a woman behind me because you
you like we were together and i was high
and i turned around and they called they
must have called your thing and you just
took off
and i froze for a second i don't play
games yeah yeah yeah and then you try he
did cut her off that's right and i
turned around i said he was with me
i said well we're flying together
jesus christ he just took off
i i think the
most important thing why i did this
podcast
one of the things i wanted to get out
there was that
the society one of the biggest
beside your family you know your family
always supports you
your friends don't support you they
break your balls about whatever you want
to do
but
everything else points to you for
failure
and if i would have believed any of that
failure i would have done nothing with
my life
nothing with my life
i never believed it
i never believed it
just how a carpenter gets better by
overcoming objections and
you know a plumber gets better an
electrician comes in and goes oh my god
i didn't know about this wall before we
put the bid in
all that [ __ ] that experience i think
that
we have that
but at times we're scared to [ __ ] use
it
the
purpose of this podcast was to
prove to people that they were lying to
us in every single aspect from going to
college to trying to better to get off
drugs
to do something with your life once you
get off prison
to go for something you believed in when
i first saw the sides for the longest
year out i didn't give a [ __ ] i was
getting that movie
even if i had to kill whoever got it the
week before run them all with a car on
the wilshire boulevard like tupac
or biggie
that was it i knew i was getting this
[ __ ] movie
that was italy in my mind i'm like i'm
getting this [ __ ]
so this is what this podcast is about
it's not about anything [ __ ] else
it's about letting you know that you
want to be an entrepreneur an
entrepreneur whatever the [ __ ] the word
is right i don't know
you can do it
i don't give a [ __ ] what objection they
tell you
your job is to find a way
plain and [ __ ] simple just find the
[ __ ] way
you know i wasn't ready for l.a when i
came here i'll tell i'll tell everybody
on this [ __ ] podcast as a comedian
as a human being i wasn't ready for l.a
when i got here but i stepped up once i
got here
once i got here something made me get to
the comedy store in these other places
and i was on the drugs for a long time
but i kept
moving i kept moving i didn't let the
drugs take me down the drugs were part
of who i was
it wasn't who i was you know i'm saying
i wasn't at home shooting and hanging
out with degenerates i was just a closet
[ __ ] uh
functioning addict as they call it i
guess that's all he's a functioning
what that means is i snorted coke and
still slung dick okay that's what that
[ __ ] meant so uh that's it that's it
and that's that that's what the podcast
is about yeah because they they do they
scare you they make everything so hard
and make everything so expensive whether
it's in college whether it's in life
there's always people telling you that
it's gonna be tough the decision you're
gonna make and you know what man
it's as tough as you [ __ ] let it
your mind overcomes all that [ __ ] you
look at it just another [ __ ] day to
do in business
it's so weirdly you just look at it it's
just another day of doing [ __ ]
business so
it was tough for me
it was tough for me in seattle in that
[ __ ] office i slept in and [ __ ] out
the window
it was tough for me when i first got
here i lived with stanhope
you know i lived with a girl in the
[ __ ] trailer
but i knew it was what i wanted to do
and i knew it was all i had and i had to
go for it
i didn't have time to dick around the
last thing i wanted to do was [ __ ]
fail and have to go back to jersey
or boulder and say i tried l.a you have
to be a gay guy to live there and suck
people's dick no you know
you just got to get up in the [ __ ]
morning and go for it and there's got to
be no waste in your [ __ ] day and
everything that you're going to do has
to be worth it from a to z
there's no wasting your day regardless
of what's going on
that's the other thing that we fall for
that's where the consistency comes in
that you don't give a [ __ ] what's going
on this is what you're doing today
this is what i'm doing today i don't
know what you're talking about
i'm not taking through a dodge again i
don't know what you're talking about
this is what we have to do it's 100 it's
100 degrees i thought we could go to the
beach i don't know what you're talking
about
i don't know what you're talking about i
got an agenda
and this is what i need to do every
[ __ ] day to get to where i need to go
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
who told you whatever this is what i do
it's so weird that's the hardest thing
and that goes for girlfriends friends
family members you know your mom calls
you
hi lee it's mom
i'm gonna come out there wednesday the
21st to and you're like mom i'm looking
at my book it's not a good time
you could stay here but i can't go to
politically correct with you
i can't go eat you know and they they
they look at you wrong but you explain
to them and you tell them the truth it's
not like you're banging some chick in
the ass and you're hanging out with
somebody else it's the truth
and you find you know you take two hours
from one day you get them two hours
early and you sacrifice these are the
things that
and dog it killed my relationship with
the stripper
because her family would always come out
here and i didn't give a [ __ ] about her
family it had nothing to do with me
it had nothing to do with me you're a
canadian yeah and she's one of those
people who likes to have dinner parties
and tell people you know let's meet at a
restaurant and then you got to sit there
for two hours at a restaurant talking
[ __ ] you know me we we get the [ __ ] out
of there right or wrong yeah it was the
last time we lurked at a [ __ ]
restaurant never we're eating the
dessert the guys already got our credit
card like we're out of here i don't want
to [ __ ] sit there and talk like with
friends and [ __ ] for eight hours ain't
nothing to talk about so i couldn't live
like that she got pissed off at me
that's why we broke up that was one of
the reasons really towards the end of
this no and if you asked terry
next time we you you and tyria together
and we'll put together we'll go tell him
about his first four years
i didn't give a [ __ ]
this is what i do we don't have time to
[ __ ] around
you want a life i want a life you think
we we [ __ ] around we're going to have a
live right now what do you think houses
cost
cars we think [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] costs money
we got this is what you need right to
have a good time for us to have a good
time
we need cash but let's do this let's
sacrifice two [ __ ] years
don't come home
work to your face is [ __ ] purple
satellites get in there and work for
overtime i don't give a [ __ ]
and you sacrifice for one or two years
and all that [ __ ] you want eventually
you can have
and that's at any [ __ ] level and
that's what i did with comedy i didn't
give a [ __ ] about your party
you know when i first got here you know
until this day i've never gone to a josh
wolfe family party
really yeah because you always had them
on saturdays at 10. if you're atomic
you're working saturday at that
i got no time to go to your [ __ ]
family reunion nothing like that i never
had time for none of that [ __ ]
i just talked to the [ __ ] girl about
the wedding in jersey i just put the
cards on the table like last week we had
a nice talk and she understands
and she goes i know i know you're
[ __ ] busy i got no time to [ __ ]
sit there from wednesday and saturday
commiserating at a wedding are you
[ __ ] crazy
no i would lose my [ __ ] mind if i had
to do something like that you killed
them by the thursday huh you killed them
by like thursday or friday i killed
myself
anyway
as usual my favorites
if you like lifting working out
you know if you like your nuts in one
spot this is the [ __ ] deal for you
picture a world where putting on a new
pair underwear isn't just fresh you're
stepping into a better day can you
picture that you're like when i get out
of this [ __ ] shower i'm gonna step
into a better day think about it
underwear is the first thing you put on
the morning and the last thing you take
off why
would you settle for anything less than
the best feeling underwear on the planet
beyond these focuses solely on producing
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever experienced
my friends at me andy sent me a few
pairs a while back and i can't imagine
wearing anything else and that's all i
[ __ ] wear lady at the massage the
chiropractor was giggling i had the
leopard print on here
i had to tell her for the price of two
cocktails me undies will deliver your
new favorite pair underwear right to
your doorstep
better day guaranteed try them on if
they aren't the most comfortable best
feeling undies you've ever had they'll
refund you and let you keep the the
first pay for free
including the price is the sweet touch
of modal a special fabric
made with the best in class raw
materials that are scientifically proven
to be three times softer than cotton
plus when you sweat i don't know what
happens with me on these i'm telling you
guys your nuts don't [ __ ] stink these
uber cozy undies are sold exclusively on
the me undies website where you enjoy
free shipping
in the us and canada you understand me
and here's where it gets [ __ ] up i
love me undies it's the only pair
underwears i had on i'm an old-school
[ __ ] for years i wore the cotton
whitey things [ __ ] those things once
they sent me on these they're tight they
keep everything tight they're away from
your muffler so you have no skid marks
all that type of stuff right so let's do
this and for a little a limited time
everyone in my audience get 20 off their
first order but you have to go on our
special url
meundies.com
joey with me on these better day
guarantee you have nothing nothing to
lose plus uncle joey's telling you these
are the nicest softest most comfortable
[ __ ] underwear you'll ever wear so
don't wait any longer go to the
undies.com slash joey right now for
twenty percent off your first order and
it gets delivered right to your door
again that's meundies.com
joey give him a shot take a chance
columbus did [ __ ] it's a new year
you want a sling dick over the holidays
put on me undies they're probably gonna
have a christmas [ __ ] print with like
a reindeer getting his [ __ ] licked
this is what you need in your life go to
beyond these dot com slash joey another
thing i want to talk to you people about
all right
uh magazines are where it's at you
travel
everybody wants to keep up on
certain little current affairs that they
you know some people like to hear about
gossip some people want to read about
the new cars that are coming up some
people like rolling stone like myself
for uh for music and [ __ ] like that
thanks to pizza we're all benji thanks
to netflix we all binge watch
but now with texture you can start binge
reading trust me it should be about one
thing when it comes to magazines you
know what you like and with texting you
get all the magazines you want in one
super convenient place
the texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines anywhere
using your smartphone or your tablet
breeze through thousands of your
favorite magazines including back issues
and pick the articles that interest you
the most
texture has made it easy to find
articles you care about
i don't just get to read the you know
these articles i get to to live them you
understand me the texture of the
auditorium team recommends content for
me every day plus i dive deeper with the
personalized collections listen to these
magazines okay you got lulu french house
beautiful in style
pc magazine 17 shape magazine sports
illustrated kids sports illustrated do
you have rolling stone in this
[ __ ] whole number national
geographic you got the hollywood
reporter new yorker time vanity fair
women's day vegan times women's health
yoga journal and the list goes on and on
and on all right the best part is sign
up for protection right now and you'll
gain access to all the content in the
world's best publications like the ones
i just read to you the best part is
texture's offering my listeners a free
trial right now when you go to
texture.com
joey again you'll gain immediate entry
into all the top magazines including
back issues and a bonus video content
start binge reading right now for free
right now when you go to texture.com
joey one more time texture.com
joey
what do you guys a big favor
i've been learning how to use this thing
they sent me this little uh
cat feeder kind of uh uh thing
machine that i'm learning how to use it
my wife's got it down with the app
listen to me we're thrilled to partner
with you
and what what listen i am thrilled to
have patnet smart feeder for cats and
dogs okay
uh my wife just got we just got it last
week and my wife is learning the app and
how to do it
uh do you ever wonder if you're over
feeding your animal
if you're over feeding your pet sure
studies show feeding your pet the right
amount every day will help them live
longer but how do you know you're
feeding your pet the right amount of
food each day all right
i'll tell you how introducing the pet
net smart feeder the new smartphone
control
automatic pet feeder that personalizes
listen to me it personalizes your pet's
daily calorie intake using their age
weight activity level and food type with
the pet net app you can schedule and
monitor your pets meals all from your
smartphone meaning your pet is always
fed even when you're running late even
when you're not home
you can stop worrying about feeding your
pet the wrong amount of food every day
the patinet smart feeder will feed the
healthiest portions at the right time
every time automatically listen we all
love our pet and the patinet smart
feeder is the best way for you to make
sure you're feeding them the right
amount every day but these things are
popular and since the patinet smart
feeder is produced in a limited quantity
each month you need to get yours before
they sell out do me a favor at
shoppetnet.com
joey today and you'll get free shipping
too right now go to shoppetnet.com
joey and you'll get free shipping too
personalize the way personalize the way
you feed your pets with petnet so do me
a favor get your pet net smart feeder
right now plus free shipping when you go
to shoppetnet.com
joey again that shoppetnet.com
joey go take a look
this is the future this is one of the
my cats love it my cats love it my
wife's got it on a timer i'm gonna ask
her this weekend exactly all the i don't
use apps too much i'm not a big [ __ ]
nap guy i don't know what i'm doing lee
always has to help me with [ __ ] apps
and whatnot but this is the future if
you love your animal this is the way to
go all right again
go to shoppetnet.com joey take a look
see what you like i'm going to give you
free shipping when you go to
shopbatnet.com
joey all right
and that's it i want to thank my little
brother lee syed
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys i'm off this week next week
i'm at the south point casino in las
vegas the only place where lee's banned
from
and then 11 11 i'm at boston at the
wilbur theater a few tickets left there
and at 11 12 i'm at the fox woods
[ __ ] country club and
connecticut [ __ ] show starts at 7 30.
be there or be square [ __ ]
listen thank you for this week i had a
great week with you guys thank you for
believing in the podcast thank you for
listening to us and thank you for the
love you give us all right uh we'll be
back
sunday night great little early podcast
so you have your [ __ ] nice and early on
monday morning all right i want to thank
my little brother lisa and you
[ __ ] for listening i'll see you
guys next week have a great weekend stay
black [ __ ]
so
you